hear me okay so this is a presentation
on the work that we did sponsored by an
IR power on how to do real-life
practical database queries is joint work
with a lot of people in Colombia Steven
Bella win single choice Ben fish Wesley
George Angeles Kermit is Fernanda Krell
abhishek kumar subramanya on da Malkin
vasilis papas bimbo and some others or
just like we're talking to and
discussing things so at this point
you're probably wondering what blinds
here stands for and how how do we come
up with such a perfect acronym that
exactly reflects what we're doing right
so this is something that we're actually
very proud of and the blind seer stands
for bloom filter index search of
encrypted results so i will talk about
yeah I I don't have time for that it's a
you know it's it's an inside job for
like my age people who are born in the
Soviet Union and older thank you okay so
I discuss what the problem is and then
at a very high level our approach and
then several selected subtleties that
that we came across so the building a
big system here and there's a lot of
aspects and it's there is a central
story which is the high level approach
but then there's a bunch of small
problems that are interesting but not
like a big deal so that I wanted to just
to get a feeling of what what things
that come up in practice and I think
that by doing this project we learned a
lot of things about what are maybe the
real practical things so one thing I
want to do several things i wanted to
share is that that some some secure
computation scenarios that I think are
our practical and it will be interesting
to you know the directions for
improvement kind of what what would be a
good thing to improve to work on okay so
this is what we're doing we want to have
a medium-sized or large size maybe later
but sort of medium time medium-sized
database for today like hundred million
records kind of representing maybe a
population of a country and you want to
be able to run a pretty rich set of
queries on that okay and just just my
kind of think of standard minus QL or
standard databases and you have to run
it fast we cannot afford what typically
in cryptography people are giving
themselves so we really should be a you
know small factor slower than the plain
text database search okay so this is the
architecture we almost immediately we
had to kind of give up on the two-party
scenario because that's like it's really
complicated yeah so we give ourselves
some help we're splitting the data owner
into two parties the server and what we
call index server so the server is the
guy who owns the data and what he's
going to do he's going to do some setup
to construct some encrypted index and
give it to this other guy who might be
in the cloud who might be I don't know
somewhere else and then that guy was
actually is going to be talking to the
client ok so we declined here step one
do a search request and then get back in
cryptid records there is a step two
missing and that's a policy check which
is important for many practical
databases you don't want the client to
ask arbitrary questions on unreal data
so this is what we're solving because of
the requirements because you know here
we faced with the with the you know real
time deadlines that the requests are
coming in and either you meet the
deadlines or you cannot use the system
right so we had to make some kind of
very basic you know right away decisions
and some of them is that we are okay to
live with some leakage so some security
loss so the transcripts the views of the
secure computation will tell you a
little bit about the date and the
question to which we have very partial
answer is that the question is how bad
is this and I have time I'll give some
comments on what we think or you can
catch me later I don't know go in depth
and so sort of some natural trade-offs
that it seems hard to avoid and we live
with them is that we're doing also the
search is based on tokens when you only
quality test for tokens and we have to
do it all the time and we cannot afford
to do proper encryption with randomized
encryption we want to compare into
encrypted things we want to know right
to where the equal or not so we're going
to use the terminus take encryption and
we dealing with the large databases so
we cannot afford any kind of linear data
structures so we in sub linear we're
going to have to traverse some of the
data using some kind of path in the data
structure we represent our stuff and the
adversary can observe this path and
maybe learn something from it so that's
what we call the access patterns and
we're going to release some of them in
the view okay all right so this is what
we're doing and now how we're doing it a
basic primitive that I think it's very
useful primitive and secure computation
is bloom filter because it allows for
constant time query so it doesn't depend
on your data it doesn't depend on it you
just check certain number of points it's
efficient storage for large data sets
for big data this is important and the
fixed access pattern you just access
those points and match or not match you
don't like your access does not depend
on on own success of it doesn't
it doesn't depend what there was a match
or not okay so we're using an encrypted
one filter so when sorry encrypted
objects there so that's important okay
so now how we doing it so let's let's
start with a very simple case let's say
we have a database with only a few
records or even a one record that has
some keywords and we know the list of
keywords that is associated with this
record and I want to return this record
based on a single keyword if that
keyword is in that record then you
return it and if not then not so then
the bloom filter gives you just that it
sits right away right the client has a
keyword that he wants to ask he will
generate a number of lube filter
positions you will send those positions
to the server the server checks in
return so this is a kind of almost a
secure way of doing it okay great but we
want to do a little want to do better
than a single keyword search so to do a
formula this doesn't quite work but the
next kind of testing and this is we're
getting to the core of what we do all
the time all day long kind of in a when
we run this so we're going to do a
secure computation to a formula match so
the way we do it is that the server has
the bloom filter that represents the all
the keywords in in the record we're not
going to give him the bloom filter we're
going to give him a one-time pad at
bloom filter and that one-time pad that
was used we're going to give to the
client this can be sued a randomly
generated one time paso client only has
a short seed okay and now we're going to
run a secure computation in a way that
the client tells which positions he
wants to look at the index server will
look up those positions also be masked
so he'll input those values into six
your community into the secure
computation the garble circuit the
client will input his one-time pad into
that secure computation you do X or then
you do an end on all these bits then you
know if the keyword was matched but it's
all done inside of the garble circuit so
nobody knows what happened whether there
was individual keywords matched or not
and then you can actually really
evaluate the boolean formula whatever
that
your circuit implements right that you
can evaluate and you will learn whether
the formula was mashed or not ok and
then based on that you can either return
the record or not ok so if you have the
database of a single record or a couple
of Records then that works pretty well
but for many records this is a natural
extension and this is what we're doing
we're going to create a bloom filter
tree where each record so with this
record we're going to associate a bloom
filter just like I said a moment ago and
then at each internal nodes we're going
to have a bloom filter that includes all
the key words of all the children and so
when we actually searching for something
we're going to start from the root we're
going to see if the formula matches here
and then you know let's say it matches
then we're going to proceed with all the
children and we're going to go all the
way down and return the right record so
this is what we do and this works and
it's all great this is very vaguely a
security guarantee that we have so what
what can you learn what can the server
learn survival learn that roughly this a
simple query or complex query because
the size of the circuit will kind of
tell you what what is going on this is
the most important linkage and this is
will be very interesting too we don't
have a good answer I quote that that
leakage means so this is the three
search pattern because when you execute
the query you see which notes you visit
it and when you execute several queries
you start accumulating some information
and you know we thought about it and
clearly for some databases for some
types of data this is clearly bad types
of queries that we want to process and
for some is not too bad or you know we
think is ok but where is the line
exactly
we don't know so that's just something
or like a fundamental research question
okay so this was a kind of basic
overview of the system and now I wanted
to just mention a couple of things that
we came across that were interesting
worth mentioning so one is the saddle
t-that's to do with the data
representation by the bloom filter and
so this is a bloom filter and lets you
know let's say a is the bits that are
set if Asians if is inserted this bits
are said B says these bits and see the
basic response to see are either in a or
b right so then if you query for a and a
is there in fact we for B is there then
you know that sees their well you kind
of know it's actually don't know if
she's there this is what bloom filter
falls positive gives you and it's it's a
problem for some things that you want to
deal with but it doesn't tell you
anything about the underlying data and
to everybody knows about the bloom
filter false positive but if you look at
the same thing from a different angle at
least for me it was new and I didn't
realize it's the same a and B and C if
you look at a is there and you know that
Nazi so the sea is not there then
without query for be you would know that
B is not there alright and this this
relates to the original data is not due
to the bloom filter representation so
without queering for B you might be able
to learn that B is in the database or
the B is not in the database and it's
not great because you know maybe the
your policy does not allow the query for
be right so this is something that at
least to me was an interesting aspect of
the bloom filter we didn't so the way we
deal with it is that we designed the
system parameters that such scenario is
not likely to happen
another interesting and this is like to
do what how things are in practice that
sometimes the security requirements that
come just kind of don't make sense and I
think everybody who worked on this one
when we're told that this is the tsunami
we need to do this every was surprised
like why so the question or the security
requirement is that the server should
not learn whether there was no matches
to the database or a single match in the
database and the question is y 0 and 1
or why not 0 and 10 or why not five and
six right and there is a reasonable
explanation so think of the government
scenarios where for example airline and
the sort of the standard situation is
when when you're looking for matches for
suspicious persons then you don't find
them in the passenger manifests right so
this is you expect to always see zero
records and when you see a one record
then there's an exception and this can
be disruptive if the the cloud server or
the airline or somebody else learns that
there is there's an exception to normal
process so this this was an interesting
kind of security requirement and another
interesting thing that how we dealt with
it I think so the most natural way for
me I think usually cryptographers we
think that okay so how do we say that
something is good and you say that bad
things don't happen right so we consider
the probability of a bad band and I will
prove that that probability is small but
we we thought about it we couldn't come
up with a good protocol efficient
protocol that would give us this
property so we went another way so this
is another how practice is that you have
a real problem and if you can solve it
you can massage it something else and
you can if you're good then you can do
it successful and convince the customer
that that's fine right but in this case
I hope that also convince you that this
is fine so what we want to say that
instead of that the bed event doesn't
happen is that you can't really tell
maybe you can tell the
it's may be worse than usual but you're
not really sure right so
cryptographically speaking that's not a
secure thing but in practice that is
fine and let me just to give a more
concrete explanation of what this means
suppose that so we know that you know
maybe we expect that once every month or
something you will see a one hit on the
airline lists right so the probability
of a1 case was delta and what we prove
that after the execution conditioned on
the execution view the a posteriori
probability of over one case doesn't
grow too much so you had some confidence
before you executed the protocol that it
was some delta probability of exception
and now you have maybe you know two
times delta but because the original
data was tiny you're not scared you
don't need to know Delta yeah and the
way we deal with it we create fake paths
in that in the search tree because you
know that you return something if you
traverse the tree to the root to the
leaf in any return right so what we do
we create several fake paths and that
that works out much time I have that
means hmm okay so everything I said is
about isn't a semi honest model and we
were allowed to deal with the semi
honest model and we wow that's what
gives the sameness model a bad name
maybe that it's just so easy to cheat in
this way that you know formally we're
secure but if you explain to somebody to
say this doesn't look right so what we
did is that we need to make sure that
the query that's been executed is an
authorized query right so what we do in
the semi honest model we send this query
we do a secure computation between the
client and the query checker right that
tells you this query is allowed or not
and then if it is allowed then we ask
this query here okay well clearly the
client the only thing that he has to do
to
it is to ignore the answer here and just
ask the query that he wants to do right
and now of course you can compile it in
a you know in a malicious secure
protocol but that that step of merging
these two things will be an expensive
step so yeah and we had to do this we
had to really convince the customer that
there is no easy way to circumvent all
this stuff and and we didn't have any
leeway in terms of performance too we
couldn't all of a sudden have factor 4e
overhead on the client so what what we
did we actually have zero overhead in
the end now in two minutes I'll try to
explain what what we did it it's not
hard but it's interesting we reverse so
the garbled circuit has the very nice
property that the evaluator cannot cheat
right so now instead of the client
generating the circuit we're going to
ask the index server to generate the
circuit okay well the problem is that
the index server does not know what is
being asked right so instead we're going
to generate a garbled universal circuit
and the query checker will generate the
policy circuit and they can talk to each
other to synchronize the keys in a way
that when the client submits went to
decline programs the universal circuit
that same programming will be also fed
as input to this circuit and so you can
see there's no way to submit different
programming right to this circuit end to
this query and sort of as a picture you
can look at it this here so this is the
universal circuit so this is a ? gate
that the index server does not know how
to program right and the input of the
client programs these gates right this
is single be the programs here and gate
or gate and that same input because
we're on one OT that same input will
guaranteed to be fed into the policy
check circuit
and then in the end you do a conjunction
of those things so it's it all works out
but even better this Universal gate can
be implemented at no cost like this with
free X orse so if this is so we're
revealing the topology of the circuit
but given that the topology of the
circuit is fixed we can program the gate
without revealing what it is and this is
the way how to do it with three XOR
gates which are free so there is it
turns out we have almost zero overhead
compared to the semi honest client she
was surprising okay so there is a sum
now I think something that might be
interesting at least to me is
interesting because a lot of things that
that we learn the tire learned is what
are you know nobody really knows what
are the practical applications like what
is the problem that people want to solve
and this I can argue that this is a
reasonable reasonably motivated problem
of for secure computation so there are
several things i wanted to mention one
is that how to construct the universal
circuit for a small set of circuits so
think about so what I said earlier is
that we have a policy topology is leaked
right all right so let's say that there
is a there is a policy that says you can
ask this query or this query or this
query right I want to hide which query
I'm asking right so my circuit I found
the client the circuit that i'm sending
you should not be able to tell which of
the three policies I'm executing right
so this is exactly the problem of
running a universal circuit just for the
small set of circuits so you can
implement any of the three circuits
using with that you versatile circuit so
people solve the nurse'll circuit
problem in generality but what here i'm
saying is that i think it's a it's a
very useful problem for for small
specific types of functions so here
really what is important is throughput
it's not important it's not that
important how my
you wait for the query what is important
is the rate of your query so if you're
thinking you know for example passenger
manifests chicks or financial
transactions global financial
transactions and you know some agencies
mining that for for money laundering
offer for fraud transactions or for
whatever is not authorized those things
it doesn't matter if you answered your
question within like 10 milliseconds or
10 seconds what matters is that overall
you're able to maintain the rate that
you want to the that is specified by the
by the requirements of the system sort
of similar in many of the applications
that i think we our system might be
useful there is no opportunity for
offline face like for example the air
the planes are flying all the time and
the financial transactions globally are
done all the time so there's no time for
you to pre-compute a lot of stuff and
then you do a real quick thing instead
you just you know you're always busy so
in this specific scenario there is
offline face is not really helping us
and we do if you look at our circuit
we're doing a lot of small circuit
evaluations and if you look at how we
search we have like a search frontier
right and for a large circuit the
frontier can be very large can be
hundreds of thousands eventually because
we if we dealing with hundreds of
millions of of records right so there is
a garble circuit bashing that is an
important issue here the circus that
we're dealing i think are like this
they're small and shallow circuit well
yeah log depth right because we we get a
bit well gets the number of this week
for them and then we do an end and that
means the key word there or not and then
you do a formula so the circuits that we
typically would see are now
Bravo tease that you have is close to
the number of gates and another thing is
that we have a server there who is
sitting doing nothing and he might be
able to help us with malicious security
to it's another thing that if you server
and but as doesn't know the circuit
right so can the server help us a
demolition secure computation in this
setting so I think I'm good on time
don't finish here for the malicious
security you have like an ideal
functionality but yeah yes so it's all
probably secure but we embed leakage
into our definition yeah yeah yeah
crystal out of context do you care about
concurrent security when you're watching
yes we with we we do yeah
how fur what about how do we do them so
how do we do boolean searches so like if
you if you do an arbitrary for me like a
or b and c for example something like
that right so this is or
so this is where it is kind of explained
but without the picture gets
unfortunately so so this light explains
how we do boolean search on a on one
record so we this is a bloom filter that
corresponds to a record and we're
running a secure computation where the
inputs to secure computation will be the
bloom filter positioned so the server
inputs a mask bloom filter positions
that the client specifies that
correspond to the terms of the boolean
formula the client specifies the mask
that's input to the secure computation
to the garbled circuit then inside the
garbled circuit we unmask right and then
we do an like for each keyword we do an
end and that value will tell you whether
the keyword is there or not I sets aside
the secure computation and then we do a
formula whatever the client wants to do
right then it's it that's how he
generates the circuit so if you want to
do a and B or C then that's that's what
the circuit specifies and the output of
the circuit would be so one thing that I
didn't mention is that we don't do
negations you have to have monotone
circuits and the reason for that is that
if you don't have a monotone circuit
then you cannot truncate the tree search
so that doesn't work so we do negations
as a as a primitive at the higher level
of MySQL but we implemented using
different technique using set
intersection using using ranges yeah
question about your tray bloom filters
so bloom filters typically you have the
size of the table for the bloom filter
just the correct not a record you
covered by a very high dynamic range
yeah so in the databases that we dealt
with which is kind of population
databases right a lot of the keywords
would repeat between right so so if this
is a person and this is a person
everybody is a person right then there
wouldn't be so many different names
right so the size of this bloom filter
is much much smaller than the sum of
these bloom filters if you have a
database that has random data in it then
this will you know it will be worse
performing so you have to have a huge
one so to give you a feeling also for
sizes four hundred million for the day
day database that represented hundred
million people this we had okay so we
had depth ate a fan-out 10g so that 100
million records write this column to
this wherever the leaves together were
about twenty five gigabytes of data and
the route was about half a gigabyte of
data so so the way we did it is that we
fit try to fit everything in rom on that
because of the disk access issues that's
that's a huge impact so we didn't want
to deal with that so to begin to give
you a feeling of what what you need for
100 million population database we were
able to fill it in like ninety six
gigabytes of RAM for pretty rich search
types that we can do
oh yeah the false-positive i forgot the
same as yours would okay so it was yeah
well I'm so false positive is an issue
but you can one way of doing it is you
can you don't need to worry about too
much about false positives here actually
if you have highs for high false
positive here that's good for security
because you get noise in your three
search patterns and it's hard for the
adversity to understand what is going on
you only really need to have low false
positive on the leaves because that's
when you're returning the data and I
don't think we use different one I think
it's maybe no point zero one percent
that's number i'm kind of remembering
but that's probably do roughly the order
that we're achieving
more questions I think you talked only
about either semi honors or but this is
security so some water by covert but
with that what is that rate up somehow
ever would it was a new better not well
so um let's go there yeah i think we
thought about it hmm we get malicious
well so we really wanted the malicious
against the client right so there was
somehow there was more trust in the
server and if we have malicious against
the client sorry if you're dealing with
the client then we got militias for free
right so I mean you can get covered for
the same price right but malicious is
better okay